انتاج كهرباء حلال ممكن ان تعتقد الوهله
الاولى ان هذا العنوان افتراضي ولكن هو
حقيقه واقعيه فالحكومه الاسرائيليه وافقت
على خطه لانشاء شبكه لتخزين الطاقه في
مدنها بهدف انتاج كهرباء متوافقه مع
الشريعه اليهودي او باختصار حلال وبالتالي
يمكن لليهود المتدينين استخدامها ايام
السبت وفق تعاليمها التي تمنعهم من
استخدام الكهرباء يوم السبت والانشغال
تماما بالعباده في هذا اليوم ففي يوم
السبت عند اليهود المتدينين لكهرباء ولا
سياره ولا تلفاز ولا حتى اجهزه الكترونيه
اما المقصود بخطه تخزينه الكهربائي لانتاج
الكهرباء حلال فهو مشروع تجريبي عباره عن
مرافق لتصنيع البطاريات بقدره 24 ميجا وات
تخزن الطاقه الزائده في اوقات ذروه
الانتاج وتستفيد منها نحو 3000 اسره
وستتول شركه الكهرباء الاسرائيليه
المملوكه للدوله بناء المرفق بتكلفه تصل
الى 33
مليون دولار
[موسيقى]